We Begin here this morning with the sudden
death of Grant Wahl a CBS Sports contributor
and the leading soccer writer in the U.S
wall was covering the Argentina Netherlands
quarterfinal at the World Cup in Qatar on Friday
when he collapsed Roxana saberi is in our London
Bureau with the latest Roxana good morning good
morning Jeff Grant Wahl was a well-loved highly
respected Sports journalist and he was kind
those close to the situation say he may have
suffered a heart attack or a pulmonary event
though the exact cause of his death is not yet
known for those of us who recently spent time
with him at the World Cup his death is a shock
the World Cup just feels like you're at the center
of the universe Grant Wahl was covering his 13th
World Cup the quarterfinal between the Netherlands
and Argentina when he collapsed last night in the
Press Box at a stadium in Qatar his agent tells
CBS News paramedics tried to revive Wahl then took
him to a nearby hospital on Tuesday the 48 year
old journalist had written he was on antibiotics
for bronchitis an illness that has spread widely
at the World Cup born in Mission Kansas Wahl
graduated from Princeton University and went on to
become one of the most renowned soccer journalists
and authors in the U.S in his popular newsletter
he wrote about the conditions of Migrant workers
building soccer stadiums in Qatar and getting
briefly detained for wearing a rainbow t-shirt
there in support of lgbtq rights as a CBS Sports
contributor his passion for soccer was clear we're
still a growing Soccer Country in the United
States with I would say millions of more soccer
fans to be created in a statement U.S soccer
said wall played a major role in helping to drive
interest in and respect for our beautiful game
adding we are devastated that he and His Brilliant
writing will no longer be with us Basketball
Star LeBron James whom wahl had featured in a
Sports Illustrated cover two decades ago also
paid tribute I'm very fond of Grant and uh
you know having that um that cover shoot you know
me being a teenager and him covering that it was
um it was a pretty cool thing wall leaves behind
his wife Dr Celine gowender a CBS News contributor
she tweeted last night she's in complete shock
Dana all right Roxana thank you very much and
we've been talking about it all morning guys it
is a shock I was amazed or maybe not amazed it
spoke volumes about what you saw on social media
everybody from an intern who worked with him to
those who worked alongside of him for years
talking about what a wonderful guy he was I
spent time with Grant I know you have two I've
interviewed him if you were going to talk to an
American journalist about soccer it was him if
you want to talk to American period about soccer
it was it was Grant he was he loved the sports
so much and he was a good man yeah yeah he was
a good man he made a lot of people love soccer too
right right men and women's soccer and certainly
our thoughts are with uh Dr Gander absolutely
and his family this morning it's a shock